my name is Dina Mufti from in jazz Egypt
and I just want to say that there is an
unstoppable energy coming out of this
new generation and it had to attach to
be channeled in the right way and if it
is channeled in the right and the right
way we could be witnessing an age of
endless creativity and innovation but
the keys are in our hands and in how we
invest in our next generation how we
invest in our young people not to depend
on government to find them jobs but to
depend on themselves and not to seek and
think of actually creating their own
self employment opportunities and that
comes through entrepreneurship and this
is one of the main things that in gezz
helps young people to do is helps them
start their own businesses while they're
still at university and so what better
way to help create your own employment
opportunity then through creating your
own business and through hands-on
learning that's the way that we're
really going to be able to to create
jobs through entrepreneurship through
getting young people to take their own
futures into their own hands thank you